[Applause]
i have been dying to see this new hairdo
on you live and in person
it's stunning i
cannot tell you how amazing it is to
feel
free free from hair color and hair
extensions and hair
tapes and blah blah blah i i feel
it it's just to be able to rub my run my
hands through my hair and
and hopefully some time a man will be
able to run his hands through my hair
and
appreciate it it's just it's heaven i'm
just
enjoying this new chapter in my hair uh
due
world have you ever had a man like drag
his
hands through your hair and hit an
extension that's a real
moment it's yeah it's um i had one time
i was
flirting with this guy's walking down
the street in new york i was just kind
of putting my hands through my hair
and and two extensions came out
and i just i i was just dropping them on
the ground i mean it's
i've had more embarrassing comments with
hair extensions coming out just
some of my my low moments and you know i
have
totally been there and yet i have really
loved all of your looks i'm a chameleon
junkie and i have
loved the effort that you have made
being the chameleon you
are with the looks you've presented over
the years i love you
thank you and you know i think that i
have i do have a great love for wigs and
i think they're so
transformative and i just i've always
even before
i made it as an actress when i was back
in new york i would put on wigs to go to
the grocery store just for fun you know
i just i
love wigs so now i can
you know everyone knows i wear a wig on
the mom program now for sure
but um i have admired you
for many years i
love what you bring to this world
how do you feel about leaving the show
it's such a huge
series and it's like the highest rated
show
do you feel like that's it we're going
out on a high i've been doing this for
years it's been a major success
and i do all these things i do movies
and
is this just a sweet chef's kiss
it's very it's very good or sweet
because i
as someone who i love being in
part of a community and you know being
part of a show like mom or
west wing or whatever movie you know how
it is as an actress it's like having a
family and it
becomes a community and it's so
important to me so
i'm sad but i also you know that we're
coming up on filming the final episode
and in some ways i i don't i don't want
to go i want to run away because i
always want to leave the party before
it's over
um i'll be apothe you know
i'll be puddles by the way i know we're
both single
and i just wanted to ask you about
something
if i may okay okay you have put out
there in the world
that you're not looking to get married
or have children
is this the truth yeah i think i
i think you know i think if i found the
right guy at the right time who wanted
to have kids i probably would have
with the right partner because i wasn't
ever really
confident confident that i wanted to
have kids and
i and i'm i would rather
uh regret not having kids than than have
kids and regret
that yeah
you know i'm okay with it i'm i'm really
i really am uh
this time of my life getting to know who
i am and what i want
so i'd love to find you know eventually
find
someone to share my life with but if it
doesn't happen i think i'll be
just fine but it would be it would be
nice right now you know what i'm doing
i'm just virtually dating with them
you know my latest crush is um uh rip on
yellowstone
oh yes oh yeah i don't know who you're
who you have a virtual crush right now
that on a show you're watching do you
have somebody
no i've been in like a really deep
rabbit hole of like disturbing
documentaries so definitely no one
there i went on a dating app for a
little while
because i was like oh no that this is
the please this is the modern world
is that anyone fun calling i think it
was uh
tom cruise calling me for something
he just keeps calling and i'm like no
means no tom right
exactly because he probably wants to get
married and have kids
um and by the way i'm the biggest dog
lover and you are a huge animal rights
activist
and you have three dogs tell me all
about it
my dogs those are my babies there the
picture of um
sippy and dutch the day i brought them
back from the pound in
mississippi when i was filming the the
help um
and um those were the babies i rescued
so i support whatever i can do to help
animals is they are my they are my
people they're my tribe
i've got them all around me here but you
can't see them because they're all
napping they're very bored with my
my interview i guess i am so excited
because
one of my passions is home decor
and i have to say as someone my first
rescues i was 19 years old and i've been
rescuing and fostering ever since
and in all that time i feel like
the pet decor industry has been
a little bit challenging when you try to
set up like a really chic
area and you bring in the pet beds and
the bowls and the supplies
it's a little hard to mix and match
those styles do you ever have that
problem
um i have i mean basically my house is
is a dog crate it's my dogs are
everywhere but
my the beds that i have are not
coordinated
well there's an expert here at the show
and i was wondering if when we come back
from commercial break
if it's okay he's gonna reveal to us
what's
possible in the pet habitat world of
design
i love it okay and guess what
he's doing it for you it's nate berkus
yeah i mean nate uh
was one of the producers on on the help
which is where i
i rescued two of my doggies so
that's kind of a wonderful coincidence
feels very full circle and we can honor
your doggies and he's gonna show us
what's possible
i can't wait all in honor of you and
your three dogs
[Music]
you